the jurgen experience this is our 50th
year
alex and i that's crazy why is it crazy
it's just
amazing you know crazy in a wild and
awesome way
you know the fact that you guys have
been doing music for that long i mean
that's pretty incredible
we came out of this music three weeks
out of high school graduation okay our
parents were very insistent
i feel like i'm watching a movie i've
seen it all play out right now yeah
is uh the van halen's their father their
mom said you're moving out okay they had
jobs set up for them at the airport no
she had his baggage antlers
okay um i had been tossed out of my
house
by mom mostly halfway through high
school
okay halfway through high school she
said out yeah what did you do
um well i made my way ultimately i
moved in with dad but i finished high
school no but i mean what'd you do that
makes
made her kick you out of the house i was
a troublesome kid
okay i was in and out of the
busing program it was a wild and
colorful time all right this is the 60s
you follow and there was
constant conflict in terms of where the
van halen's went to school for example
as pasadena high school
is 90 caucasian we'll call it
and other i went to the schools that
were all black and spanish
speaking so when i say
i mean that al van halen
owns a 1956 bel air coupe okay with the
slicks on the back now you're talking
it's sad
okay that's pasadena high school i own a
lowered 66
volkswagen with a 383 chevy engine in
the front local
[Laughter]
it's like the balance that made our
music colorful
the my moniker diamond dave comes from
when i would go over to the van halen
side that's like ridgemont high
i went to like coulee high all right and
their music was all led zeppelin stones
the who sabbath like this
and starting at the seventh grade um
youth club dance for me that was all
motown which
you know later my record collection was
everything from
rick james and you know the funk i took
eddie van halen to his first black
concert at the forum
i think it was the only one that he ever
went to was earth wind and fire
whoa you saw earth winning fire live
1976
when all the hits lifted up every famous
earth wind and fire
like this because i was gang signing the
whole alphabet from seventh grade on
come on
we knew where to go get clip-on ties and
see-through socks
at a meals when alex van halen and i
made our first lawsuit for 150 bucks on
somebody who welched on a check
we went to a meals and we got clip-on
ties
and we got proper socks and we went out
and
shoot him you follow you sued someone
from
somebody said uh it was the uh
and i say with respect the mayfield
school the holy child of jesus
incorporated joke and uh they said this
was 1973.
they said according to the contract that
we had been smoking marijuana
no i know i came to the right place but
save your romance as a fact we did not
that was not possible because we didn't
have enough money for it we would have
full disclosure full disclosure yep it's
for 150 bucks
so al and i and i know al is listening
right now we laugh like pirates on the
phone okay
and uh he uh uh he and i went to
um uh emails we got clip-on ties
okay and we went and we filed in the
small claims
division all right um we stood in there
and the uh uh the school showed up there
were two nuns
and a family a father a mother and two
young daughters it was quintessential
it's 1973.
in these days like for example here in
texas with long hair
whoo you better watch out over your
shoulders a very very different
background
okay this is now into any kind of
haircut
goes these days but remember long hair
in 1973
in a court of law wow you were already
on your back foot
and we stood up thought we were fooling
the magistrate you follow with our long
ponytails remember what i used to look
like joe he's going to look like tarzan
who read a few paperbacks come on
[Laughter]
i was you joe
look at you look at you exactly
and you know cheekbones for days man you
can sharpen a hunting knife on those
cheekbones
look at those chicks that's right
beautiful manual there we go i was
gorgeous beautiful man i launched a
thousand hips
i'm not a sex symbol you dig i'm not a
sex
object it's i symbolize it when you guys
feel sexy
i'm the m.c i make other people feel
sexy you come and you listen to van
halen music
you give me three songs you're going to
feel young and skinny
you joe will feel invincible and your
old lady will feel
eminently desirable how much is that
worth
it's inestimable you got some good
marijuana i'll tell you that
when i walked in here like when when i
got to the studios like the fog was
thick in the building as i passed
through i'm like dave must be here
yeah well i think there's definitely
benefit in kids learning martial arts
for sure
and learning martial arts in the same
uniform there's a real benefit and that
too because
you realize it's not about the uniform
it's not about what you look like it's
about getting things done
then as you learn and grow and and
become more accomplished then you
receive these belts
and so then you have goal attainment and
goal attainment
is an amazing thing for kids an amazing
thing for adults
there's a real benefit in knowing that
you put in the hard work and now there's
something that signifies it
oh my god i have a blue belt and they
tie that blue belt around your waist and
you're not a white belt anymore and you
feel proud you put that thing on
you feel like i have done work and that
it elevates
your perspective in terms of the way you
look at yourself and you look at your
abilities it gives you more confidence
and it also gives you this goal one day
i want to be a black belt
and you just think about it like one day
i'm going to attain a rank
of proficiency where i'm going to be
someone who's actually
to whatever level mastered a very
specific style of martial art that's
incredibly difficult to learn
that's going to apply that now to the
arts that we do for a living
mccartney can't get through an interview
without telling you about his six years
in the red light district in germany he
wears it
like a general's badge can you dig it
he's proud of it
alex being healing and i same thing we
put in five years compared to year three
the average is two and a half maybe
just constantly jamming doing multiple
shows constantly
isn't that that's there's it's detailed
in the book the outliers right
is it the outliers i think it is there's
a there's a book
outliers yeah that they talk about how
when the beatles emerged
people don't realize they had so many
hours of playing it's one of the reasons
why they're so good
they were they were playing so often
constantly
it is really hardcore training
and that's when you build who you are
that's where you develop your
ingredients
yeah when i was coming up in music
that was the regular because there were
bands
at every club every bar had to have a
live band
to afford the speakers and the turntable
and the music you had to have a live
band
and you would tear off the left hand
side of the billboard chart
and learn it alex and i
went through a list just recently that
we found of 120 songs
that we could play at the drop of a hat
by everybody you could imagine from
smoke on the water to get down tonight
that's where we learned to sing
get down tonight get down tonight
we didn't have keyboard so you better
sit you better sing a cover off that
[ __ ] ball
that's why mike anthony was so unique
his bass playing now we can find bass
players
but nobody sounds like that that's
garfunkel
simon's good but simon and garfunkel
where do you think you built that
thousands and thousands of vocal
training hours
so that when mike and i sing
you recognize it like hendrix's guitar
you may never have heard the song before
and you go that's hendrix
signature sound like rod stewart's voice
you may never have heard the song before
you go that's right
yeah it is and in our backgrounds like
motown
that only comes from thousands of hours
where do you learn to have the
temperature to stick with that
i learned it at the dojo i learned it in
my first
singing lessons you dig it my first
singing coach
jesus that was also my first real
experience with tattoos we started off
talking about tattoos my first singing
coach had two tattoos
he had a number right here and he had
another number right there
and he would say at least once a year
this is my camp number and this is the
number why i was still alive
he played piano and he sang at auschwitz
jesus he's there for three years
kurt blumenthal okay
and he used to tell me mr roth
sing as if your life depended on it
can you imagine a gig where one bad
review literally
puts you up the chimneys and that was
another expression he would use
it's in the music it's in my voice
it's in every van halen song you hear
mr van halen taught it to his sons
jan van halen and i were very good
friends
and he would tell his sons about when
the bombing
would start and they would all move into
the subway tunnels
and he would play saxophone for
everybody hiding
during world war ii
every time i sing i sing as if my life
depended on it
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience